i'd like to see that debate that you're
putting together i know you're working
on this i
i would easily be working on a debate
can you reveal it do you want to review
it i would love if should i reveal it
you want to review if people want to go
on twitter and say to somebody
see if the audience would be down for
this so pat how many guys would like to
see
a debate between aoc and candace owens
imagine a debate between aoc and candace
owns okay
and we do with pay-per-view style aoc
candice owens
they debate on the stage
90 minutes okay and there's a moderator
and they go maybe maybe it's got to be
more than nine but i think it's gotta be
like two hour debate
well there's a round two yeah round one
round two potentially in the uh
when we have moderator
i would be willing to pay both candice
owens
and aoc each a hundred thousand dollars
if they're willing to do that debate
i'll pay each 100 000
if they want to do that debate i have a
feeling candace owens would do it
without a you know even thinking about
it
yeah but i have a feeling aoc would turn
it down without account
i also think after the debate yeah after
the debate
in the nate robinson jake paul
logan paul oh you have some ideas with
that logan paul
and floyd mayor i think they they
straight up this fight afterwards they
get but
we have them in the ring yeah byron dell
had had an idea they want you to reveal
it though
i don't know i don't know i'm gonna
throw byron under the bus here here you
go buddy
maybe they do some mud wrestling
afterwards so that's just an idea that
our good friends put out there
to still a thing we're gonna make it a
thing we're gonna make mud wrestling
great again that's what we're gonna do
tom here on
valuetainment but you know look we have
like it's a it's like a
who would like to see that debate yeah
who would actually like to see that uh
debates
fights hundred thousand actually aoc
knows she would be exposed she would be
dressed down and destroyed
who's your favorite who's the favorite
let me ask you oh it's not even a
question but
oh you think candace is the favorite
okay by the way if you're watching this
if candace owens debates aoc who wins
the debate oh i'm talking about the
fight
oh my wrestling no that's a different
story i think aortic street
yeah that's a different story from the
streets yeah so candace owens aoc who
wins the debate
well you got to go round per round right
so who's the debate tell me who wins it
i think candace owens probably has a
better
um message right better message but who
do you think wins
i think i look i think that's going to
be pretty even stephen i think
really i think i think wow i think it's
can you order that shirt for him
order that sweater for soyboy mafia and
aoc collab coming your way
yeah i think if you did but i think aoc
would win the actual
guys thumbs up candace owens wins thumbs
down aoc wins
thumbs up candace owens thumbs down aoc
the biggest problem you'd have if this
was a two-hour event that valuetainment
was hosting what are you going to do for
the other hour and 59
after aoc taps out after one minute she
would want
nothing to do with candace oh and she
would run and hide but she could
sell her sweatshirt she could wear that
you know think the sales
be a good marketing branding idea for
her come on the valuetainment
debate the question is what would it
take for him
i'll buy sweaters that says tax to rich
text
did you see what candice owens who was
it rihanna this guy collab with
connections put ten bucks says i'll buy
both sweaters tax the [ __ ] and tax the
rich for 58 bucks each
to watch the debate nice p p i i think
we could pull this off i just don't
think aoc would do the debate
i don't either i i don't think she'll
sell sweaters but won't do a debate
no i don't think she would where do you
see aoc in the next 10 years running
running el presidente oh yeah
we need rock yeah to beat her in the
primary this is rock and aoc
run together he's the president she's
the vice president
he would never does america vote for
that he would never do that why do you
say that because he's not
politically on the same side as aoc is
but that's why he's bringing her for a
big tent
yeah but he he would he would not he
would not go with that
uh i'd love to see that debate again i
gave my offer i'm probably going to go
tweet it on again on twitter as well
and if anybody wants to retweet it i'd
love to see that happen i think it'd be
pay-per-view type of stuff and
we can even do profit sharing for both
of them nice literally whatever we sell
we would do profit sharing as well i'm
very open to like a real socialist idea
i would actually share the money
i would actually do a socialist idea
yeah we would do profit and snoop
retweets you you better tag pat
oh we would have a snoop as a
commentator snoop a loop
bring your green hat so so by the way
logan paul and mayweather said they're
gonna fight each other
snoop says i'm ready